Усі 24 українські моряки
залишаться за ґратами в Росії до кінця квітня.
Такий результат двох днів засідань
Лефортівського райсуду в Москві.
Ще один результат засідань -
вони вперше змогли побачитися зі своїми рідними,
які спеціально приїхали в Москву на суд.
Досі дружинам та матерям не дозволяли
зустрітися з моряками. Рідні зустріли їх оплесками.
Інший важливий результат: українські моряки
показали спільну позицію та одностайно відмовилися
відповідати на запитання суду.
Згідно із Женевською конвенцією про поводження
з військовополоненими, вони мають назвати лише ім'я,
громадянство, вік і сімейний стан.
Захист наполягає, що українські моряки - військовополонені,
а значить, їх треба визнати такими
та перенести справу в Московський військовий суд.
Це класичний збройний конфлікт.
І ті, хто вважає, що військовополонені бувають лише в результаті оголошених воєн,
це неправильна позиція. Женевська конвенція передбачає
статус військовополонених для тих, кого захопили,
зокрема і в результаті неоголошених воєн,
збройних конфліктів без оголошення війни.
Проте суд відмовив у цьому клопотанні.
Офіційна позиція російської влади така:
між Україною та Росією немає війни,
тому моряки - не військовополонені,
а порушники кордону, справу яких має розглядати кримінальний суд.
А от на що суд погодився -
так це на прохання обвинувачення зробити усі засідання закритими,
адже процес, мовляв, неординарний.
Тож із суду всіх попросили -
зокрема і вісьмох дипломатів з Євросоюзу,
США, Великобританії та низки країн Європи,
які приїхали на власті очі побачити процес і стан моряків,
а також почути аргументи сторін.
Для того, щоб позиція захисту не була привселюдно озвучена в залі суду,
вони таким чином намагаються контролювати інформацію
та хеджувати свої ризики, перш за все політичні, закриваючи суд.
У залі суду моряки посміхалися.
Хоча за даними української сторони, шестеро з них
потребують подальшого лікування та реабілітації.
Думаю, вже все вирішено і усі вказівки ФСБ суд вже отримав.
На вулиці під судом - акція протесту:
одиночний пікет на підтримку українських моряків.
Без дозволу можна протестувати тільки так.
У Росії є люди, які не підтримують те, що робить наш уряд,
наша влада і особисто Володимир Путін.
Адвокати моряків обіцяють подати апеляції,
і в разі потреби дійти аж до Страсбурзького суду.
Українська ж сторона перш за все розраховує на міжнародний тиск.
Я не юрист і не хочу оцінювати, але
досвід показує, що жоден з українських політв'язнів
і хлопців, які утримуються на території РФ,
за рішенням суду додому не попав.
В Україні на підтримку моряків влаштовують флешмоби.
У багатьох українських містах нацгвардійці провели акції.
Вже майже два місяці українські моряки
перебувають в ув'язненні у РФ.